one more on this so I hate to be the
Debbie Downer here but Joe Biden clearly
ain't going to do any of the draining
that you guys would like to see and that
pretty much everyone watching this would
like to see here's Biden's thoughts on
the debt ceiling they want to raise your
gas prices they want to cut taxes for
billionaires who pay virtually only
three percent of their income now they
want to pose a 30 percent national sales
tax on everything from food clothing
school supplies housing cars if
Republicans want to work together on
real solutions and continue to grow
manufacturing jobs build the strongest
economy in the world and make sure
Americans are paid a fair wage I'm ready
but I will not let anyone use the full
faith and credit of the United States as
a bargain ship the United States of
America we pay our debts oh we pay our
debts by borrowing more money to pay our
debts Jeffrey bring us home on this one
and then we'll move on to a second uh
really critically just to roll back
slightly uh on the schedule a schedule
schedule I've played the administrators
take just so we understand what Biden
stands on this within hours of the
inauguration he repealed Trump's
executive order and that's how important
it is to him the Democratic party at
this point is the sort of marionettes
for the executive uh State for the for
what sometimes called the Deep State and
that's that's what they depend on that's
what they rely on and by the way uh uh
Biden's right our cares ridiculous three
percent through the wealthy paid three
percent it's just ridiculous it's just
complete and true
um but apart from that his uh his his
rhetoric about the national sales tax
I'm telling you the Republicans made a
disastrous misstep and and talking about
a national sales tax I don't think that
would be a good reform and the Wall
Street Journal I think very
appropriately uh denounced that idea
they should I love the idea of getting
rid of the income tax I mean that's a
great idea but don't replace it with
with a European style vat or anything
close to that that's a bad idea and all
you're doing is giving fodder to the
Democrats to to continue with their lies
and nonsense
vivec just to fully bring us home on
this one you're you're doing okay I'm
guessing you're paying a little more
than three percent fair to say fair to
say
all right very good if you'd like more
sane takes on our insane World check out
our direct message clips playlist and if
you want to watch more full episodes of
our live round tables watch our round
tables playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell